Fred Rogers was a legitimate American
national treasure over 31 seasons he
proved to be the reliable compassionate
and all-wise friendly neighbor who
guided millions of youngsters through
their childhood
Fred single-handedly introduced
children's educational television in the
process elevating a medium that was
heading downhill fast his radical
kindness stupefied by a gentle and
personal manner helped bring sanity to a
world beset by problems having mr.
Rogers as our neighbor made the world a
safer place Frederick McFeely Rogers
entered the world on March the 28th 1928
at his grandparents house in Latrobe
Pennsylvania his parents James and Nancy
were extremely pious people so young
Fred grew up in a very religious
household James works at the McFeely
Brick Company which was owned by his
father he was a hard-working industrious
man who taught these traits to his son
Nancy volunteered at the local hospital
as a nurse's aide she had a deep love
for helping others which also was a huge
influence on phret in later years
Fred would fondly remember how his
mother required everyone in the family
to hand knit sweaters every Christmas
for the troops during the war years this
family ritual instilled in fret a love
for sweaters and they became his
trademark during his TV show mr. Rogers
neighborhood in years to come every one
of the hundreds of sweaters he wore on
the show was hands knitted by Nancy the
extended Rogers family was very close
with Fred developing a special bond with
his grandfather the two spent many hours
together where the old man would
encourage Fred to be himself expressing
all of his feelings and emotions freely
this had a great impact on Fred who
fondly recalled how his grandpa had told
him that he made his day special by
simply being himself those words made
Fred feel special and he made it his
mission in life to how about the people
feel the same way
[Music]
when he was 11 Fred's parents adopted a
baby girl named Elaine Fred loved being
an older brother or even though Elaine
proved to be quite a handful away from
the love and the security of his family
however Fred struggles he found it
difficult to make friends often finding
himself isolated and alone the other
children made fun of the fact that he
was overweight and that he didn't join
in with their rough-and-tumble play as a
result he became rather quiet and shy
his parents told him to ignore the
negative feelings that were welling up
inside of him and focus on positive
things this only made Fred feel more
hurt and more confused
in later years one of his key messages
to parents was that children's feelings
need to be acknowledged
rather than ignored they all led that
Fred stumbled upon to release his
pent-up emotions was the piano when he
was just a few years old Nancy would
play the piano in order to soothe fret
by five he was playing it himself he was
a natural and within a few years he was
so proficient that he would play for
guests and family members his acts who
would also include a puppet show Fred
found these outlets allowed him to
express his feelings in a way that
wouldn't upset other people when he was
10 Fred's grandmother bought in a piano
of his own a 25 dollar pump organ he
spent hours each day practicing with his
time at the keys being the only periods
that he felt like he was being his true
self in his early teens Fred also became
obsessed with photography developing his
own prints in a basement darkroom his
favorite thing to capture on film with
the expressions on other people's faces
the Roger's family they attended the
Presbyterian Church in Detroit from the
very start Fred was eager and engaged he
was entranced by every sermon finding a
personal connection to the message of
Christianity and the personality of
Jesus Christ it inspired in him the deep
felt desire to serve and help other
people
well Fred entered high school he was
just a shy and uncertain around his
peers than ever he did however develop a
very unlikely friendship fred could
never have imagined that he would become
close friends with someone like jim
Stambaugh Stambaugh was a popular and
talented athlete and a football player
when Jim suffered a football injury
however he was confined to a hospital
bed for a period of weeks the school
assigned Fred to deliver Jim's homework
to him in hospital as well as making
notes for him in class German Fred's
then time together ins came to
appreciate each other
Fred could see through Jim's exterior
image as the sports hunk and Jim could
appreciate Fred's quiet and thoughtful
nature when Jim was released from the
hospital the friendship continued
through Jim's influence the other
students came to realize that Fred
wasn't so bad after all
Fred's hadn't changed but now the other
students let him be himself without
harassing him from this he learns a
powerful lesson that he strived to
impart to millions of children through
his TV show decades later be yourself
without shame as a result of his
newfound acceptance by his peers
Fred's confidence grew in leaps and
downs he became involved in school
activities becoming editor of the school
yearbook and the school newspaper by the
end of his senior year he was president
of the student council he came to be
respected rather than mocked for his
quiet thoughtful nature during his high
school years Fred develops another
relationship that was pivotal in his
life George Allen was an
african-american friend of the family as
well as sharing Fred's passion for music
George was also a passionate pilot he
shared his enthusiasm with Fred's
teaching him to fly while Fred never
developed George's passion for flying he
was entranced by Fred's love of
imparting his aeronautical knowledge it
was then that he learned what it was to
be a true teacher
[Music]
upon graduating from high school it was
Fred's intention to go to seminary and
become a minister this seemed to be his
natural calling allowing him to serve
others just as his parents at groom Tim
still he felt a need to achieve a
college degree and his love of learning
inspired him to enroll at Dartmouth
College for his freshman year he decided
to study the Romance languages after a
year however he decided that what he
really wanted to study was music
Dartmouth had no program that was worthy
of Fred's talents so he transferred to
Rollins College it was during an initial
tour of the college that Fred ran into
his future wife Sarah Jo Ann Bird Sarah
became hugely impressed with Fred's
piano-playing ability and he quickly
became a part of her circle of friends
fred majored in music composition and
minored in french language prior to
graduation in the summer of 1951 fred
returned home on vacation he still fully
intended to attend a Theological
Seminary after graduation but everything
changed when Fred saw his first
television show on the small screen Fred
watched as two men threw pies into each
other's faces in an instant he saw the
potential in this new medium to educate
millions of people at once at the same
time he was appalled at the lowbrow way
that television was currently being used
fred was so passionate about its desire
to change the way the television was
being used that he decided on the spot
to give up on his ideas to join the
seminary and pursue a career in
television
[Music]
upon graduating from Rollins with his
music degree in hands
Fred applied to NBC television in New
York and asked if they had any positions
available he was hired by a producer
named Charles Palo Jack fred moved to
new york full of enthusiasm only to
finds that his days were spent running
minor errands he experienced the worst
in his colleagues especially those in
positions of power in later years Fred
remembers how one boss severely
chastised him in public for forgetting
to put sweetener in his coffee
he tried mostly in vain to bring a
positive vibe to the office Fred's
favorite MBC show was opera theatre the
show collaborated with famous composers
to put on operas that was shown across
the nation via the tube
Fred worked his way up to becoming a
floor manager on the show he was in
charge of timing the programs making
sure the cameras were ready and letting
the actors know when to stop and when to
start his attentive personality allowed
him to shine in this role fred also
became floor manager on a handful of
other shows he came to appreciate the
wide variety of uses that television
could be put to one of the shows he
worked on was the Gabby Hayes show he
watched and absorb the lesson as Hayes
spoke into the camera as if there was
only one person on the other side of the
screen ultimately though Fred became
frustrated NBC wasn't showing any
interest in moving into the use of
television as a medium of education he
decided to leave and pursue his passion
to bring music and education to the
masses especially children in 1953 Fred
and Sarah who had married the previous
June heard of a new television station
that was opening in Pennsylvania it was
to be called WQED they decided that Fred
should apply and he was offered a job as
a program manager WQED was the first
community television station in the
United States fred saw it as the ideal
opportunity to shape educational content
a month before WQED was scheduled to go
live the owners decided that a
children's program would be a valuable
addition to the lineup
Fred's and the young women named Josie
Carey the station secretary were tasked
with coming up with something the show
they came up with was called the
children's corner the children's corner
started out very simply while Fred
worked behind the scenes josie
introduced free children's educational
films on the night before the show aired
station director Dorothy Daniel gave
Fred a small Tiger puppet as a good
charm Fred quickly dubbed this puppet
Daniel without telling anybody Fred
positioned himself behind the set
backdrop which was simply a painted
sheet as Josie began introducing the
first episode live on the air he cut a
slit in the sheets and Daniel appeared
on-screen and began conversing with
Josie the Muppet proved to be a hit with
audiences and puppets became a regular
feature of the show on this show Fred's
he was obviously the puppeteer as well
as the organ player in order to rush
between the set and the organ he took to
wearing his trademark white tennis shoes
The Children's cornet became so
successful that Fred and JC became local
personalities the show even came to the
attention of NBC Fred's former employer
when their head of religious programming
went on a four-week vacation NBC invited
Fred and Josie to fly to New York to
appear live every Saturday morning they
returned to Pittsburgh for the Monday
morning show the NBC Saturday show now
exposed Fred to a national audience he
began receiving hundreds of thousands of
fan letters the NBC executives quickly
secured Fred and Josie as regulars they
also had larger more professional
puppets made NBC put pressure on Fred
and Josie to quit WQED and go daily on
their channel but the pair would not
relinquish their loyalty to the original
Channel and they continued to travel
back and forth
despite his grueling TV schedule Fred
continued to pursue his dream of
achieving a theological degree he
attended the Pittsburgh Theological
Seminary and studied in the late hours
finally achieving his master's in
divinity the most influential course he
took was a master's counseling course
during which he worked with children to
see how they reacted to puppet
interactions he found that children
reacted very differently with puppets
than they would with real people and
would more easily open up and
communicate with a puppet fred was
ordained in 1962 his vocation was to
work with children and families through
the mass media specifically television
plans were put in action for a Fred
hosted show for the Presbyterian Church
but before he got off the ground
Fred received the call that would change
his life
[Music]
the call came from Fred Reines burry who
was in charge of children's programming
in Canada he wanted Fred's to come to
Canada Aaron's put on a 15-minute Daily
Show specifically aimed at children and
using puppets as well as his musical
talents it was a huge risk Fred and
Sarah who now had two young children but
it was everything that Fred had been
working towards and so they bit the
bullet and moved to Toronto but when he
arrived fred was shocked to realize that
reigns Barry wanted him to appear in
front of the camera rather than behind
the scenes reins brie had seen Fred work
one-on-one with children and knew that
he had a special gift to connect with
them over the next 12 months the two
Fred's developed the program's concept
with Rogers finally agreeing to appear
on screen
the show was to be called Mister Rogers
as one word reigns Murray felt that this
would make it less formal to children
the show was set up in a neighborhood
with whimsical sets and puppets for Fred
to interact with a man named Ernie was
brought in as the puppeteer the show was
a huge success in Canada however after
the initial 12-month contract was up
Fred decided to move his family back to
the United States to be closer to family
[Music]
moving that's Pittsburgh Fred waited
patiently until WQED had room in their
schedule for another children's
educational program after two years
during which she held an education job
with the church the funding came through
for Fred to host his own show on WQED
Mister Rogers neighborhood the show
premieres in October of 1966 for the
first year it was essentially a
rehashing of the Canadian version of
Mister Rogers
within 12 months however the format had
expanded and the show had been picked up
by the Sears Company as a major sponsor
enabling it to go to a national audience
Fred wrote the theme song which was to
become famous won't you be my neighbor
the revamped show added more characters
puppets and places to visit each episode
Fred would go out of the studio and
visit a new place the second national
series in 1969 rolled out in full color
in the third season the show which had
become hugely popular was taken over by
the Public Broadcasting Service or PBS
the first run of Mister Rogers
neighborhood continued production for a
total of eight seasons and 455 episodes
by then Fred's he was ready to take a
break and so the show transition to
reruns but Fred's were still busy ever
the perfectionist he took the
opportunity to fix things that he didn't
like from older episodes new original
seasons of Mister Rogers neighborhood
began filming in 1979 between then and
fifteen new episodes were produced per
season with shows linking together and
carrying through one overall theme for
the entire season the huge popularity
over the show was due to Fred's casual
inviting and empathetic nature he never
acted always striving to be genuine and
honest his main method of teaching was
through his own example as many of his
audience members grew up with him the
show which starts with Fred's talking
directly to his child audience about a
subject then it would transition to a
field trip which had been filmed earlier
then it would be back live where Fred
would move into the neighborhood of
make-believe this was a whimsical place
where the characters could learn explore
and act out specific scenarios then Fred
would move out of the neighborhood of
make-believe and to discuss what had
happened in the neighborhood that day
from start to finish the emphasis of the
show was on communication opening up to
others and exploring feelings fred was
not afraid to discuss any topic that was
relevant to children include
divorce and death in addition to these
heavy topics read also encouraged
children to have fun exploring the world
around them and keeping their curiosity
alive in 2001 Fred retired at the age of
71 after 31 seasons and 865 episodes of
Mister Rogers neighborhood the show was
officially over but Mister Rogers was
still a familiar TV personality because
of reruns
[Music]
although he was best known for his
landmark TV show Fred Rogers invested
this time and energy into other work as
well he was involved in the children's
book business held seminars for parents
and produced many documentary style
features the most well-known of these
was a series called mr. Rogers heroes
and old friends new friends for the show
Fred traveled all over the United States
talking to admirable people Fred offered
a total of 36 children's books dealing
with issues ranging from fear of going
to the hospital to potty training
Fred's passion for children's education
led to his involvement in advocacy work
in 1979 he founded a nonprofit
organization called family
Communications Inc he also made his
voice heard on the national level when
he became involved in government issues
in 1969 he appealed to a group of
senators in an effort to stop the
federal government cutting funding to
PBS largely as a result of his efforts
the funding was actually increased by
ten million dollars in 1984 he was
called as an expert witness in a case
between Sony and the Universal City
studio the case was about the new Sony
technology called Betamax which was the
forerunner of the video recorder this
new technology threatened Hollywood
sends Universal brought the case to stop
Sony on the grounds of copyright Fred
testified on the behalf of Sony stating
the importance of parents and children
being able to tape his show for viewing
later Sony ultimately won the case
a year after his retirement from
television fred was diagnosed with
stomach cancer his last public
appearance was when he tossed the coin
at the 2003 Rose Bowl a few weeks later
he underwent surgery to get rid of the
cancer it was unsuccessful and Fred went
home to spend his last weeks with his
family he died on February 27th 2003
surrounded by his family and his devoted
wife Sarah
Fred's passing was mourned around the
world but it was felt the hardest in his
native Pittsburg Pennsylvania
his memorial was held there and it was
attended by thousands of people
including many celebrities PBS took
steps to help children to come to terms
with the loss of mr. Rogers they
continued to air reruns and a special
entitled Fred Rogers America's favorite
neighbor was hosted by Michael Keaton
during his lifetime
Fred received many awards including the
Presidential Medal of Freedom in 1999 he
was inaugurated into the television Hall
of Fame and one of his sweaters was
featured in the Smithsonian Institute as
a treasure of American history the
greatest legacy of Fred Rogers is the
show that made him a national treasure
the lessons he imparted of tolerance
compassion love and empathy are just as
relevant today as they were when mr.
Rogers neighborhood first went to air in
the 1960s so I really hope you enjoyed
that episode of biographic if you did
there's a couple of things you could do
right now one is hit that like button
below also if you want more stuff like
this we put out brand new videos every
Monday and every Thursday so hit that
subscribe button below and subscribe
button doesn't do what it used to on
YouTube if you actually want to get a
notification about these videos please
do hit that Bell button next to the
subscribe button and that'll send you a
notification every time every Monday and
Thursday won't put out a new video also
if you want to watch something else
right now stuff from the archive over
there on the right and as always thank
you for watching